hi guys I'm Greg I'm John I figured
swatch mean tweets robert de niro
edition I love mean Tweel uh my writing
me exactly yo your son of a [ __ ] you so
he says it in a and then movie replays a
Cody Al Capote your son of a [ __ ] show
I just want to welcome to my class on
imitating Robert DeNiro the first step
is to always contort your face like you
just heard you'd wear much for good good
what good is this all you have to do in
your life right these kind of things
whoever wrote this there are now two
things visible the state Great Wall of
China Rodney Rowe's tale you die you
would with these really guide you
towards the water if you probably all of
us would feel that way about you
yourself so she looks like Robert DeNiro
it's such a shame you may be gangsta
movie still do these two sucks playing
grandfather roles or something yeah I am
playing grandfather roles and pretty
should not be playing great-grandfather
roles you gotta be honest not a good
fellow he is a POS piece it you know
what you can do you can shuck my hello
whoa gross ratty old man George Clooney
can find a girl regular fellows out
there the Twitterverse must be drowning
in well I'm not expecting to never get
sensitive like I ran my gloves off gonna
rip before everybody is the dirty
grandpa there it is you defining role
now see now I just want to watch him do
this for an hour a day I just want to
eat one Robert De Niro [ __ ] you people
even actually offended I don't know if
he's like faking it or just playing
along with most people when they read
mean tweets they're kind of just like
laughing about it or think it's silly
they're all in their composure every
once in a while someone might give a
little jab people here is offended but
every single one of them
I didn't give this is me he was gonna
lose sleep over like that kind of
offended but it seemed like every time
he was like [ __ ] you like this is like
why are you when you tie do it yeah I
think De Niro
I've seen footage of like the Nero
getting mad onset at like like there was
one first one I ever saw was like a car
commercial where someone was looking to
get more emotion and he got like it's
about being directed like that yeah over
my martial and we've seen the movies we
know he can get in really thank you
forgotten for sure getting angry that
well you know sure we didn't realize
yeah yeah yeah I mean like I got the
system maybe it leads a little business
he was having fun was but yeah like I
like I imagine this is exactly what a
day on Robert De Niro's Twitter would
look like a meeting at replies to going
up [ __ ] you so great that's pretty fun
alright route of the narrow Matt I was
not I thought it was just gonna be funny
I wasn't expecting to be like whoa well
anything is like it is funny just
because like every time he just like
after the after the first couple the
more like idiotic artifices the voice
starts to let loose and it's like yeah I
just watched him talk [ __ ] on people's /
- Minh DeNiro he has a weird career
right now
he's got yeah yeah he's in like a lot of
random thing a lot of stuff he's a lot
of stuff and every like five years
season
something where he's greeting to cash a
check cashing check actually primarily
just cash his check only last time
DeNiro was a great leading role tell
them when you get the door and again oh
yeah that's great I don't know about a
leading role but I think the last great
role II have a silver linings playbook
he's pretty good enjoy he's a really
good enjoy actually I didn't seem to it
says the thing is like I feel like it
whenever he pops up to and like gets
respect lately it's been a good
supporting role yeah that seems like
where is that right now for Robert
DeNiro and then you know the occasional
dirty grandpa yeah alright guys well
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to John Humphrey on the reasons to Gerry
on Twitter and Instagram he's a social
media manager of the real rejects and
beloved II blum blum and you can catch
up on the YouTube and that's the only
platform we have because we're staying
ahead